-Ethan, you've acted in
and directed
so many great movies,
but I wanted to see if you're
a big enough fan
that you can summarize a movie
in just 5 seconds.
It is time for five-second
summaries.
-Here we go!
-♪ 1-2-3-4 5-Second Summaries ♪
-Alright bud, now here's how
the game works.
We're going to be given the name
of a movie.
As soon as you see
the title on your card
or on your screen, you have
5 seconds to describe the plot
the best you can and try to make
me guess what it is.
Alright, we're partners here.
-Okay. But I can't say
the lead actor
and I can't say the name of
the movie, or I have to --
it's like charades or something.
Right?
-Yeah. You can't use words in
the title,
can't use catchphrases,
any names.
You're just describing the plot
of the movie in 5 seconds.
-Okay, very good.
-Alright, good.
Alright, we're going to
take turns.
Ethan, since you're my guest,
you're up first.
Let's put 5 seconds on
the clock.
Take a look at the movie on
your first card,
and when you're ready, start.
-Okay.
Here we go
Peter Weir directed,
a young baby is born,
and he's on TV his whole life.
-Oh, "The Truman Show."
[ Ding ]
"Truman Show?"
That's what I'm talking about,
buddy.
All right, that's what
I'm talking about.
See, I knew it.
-Alright, you're good.
The pressure is on me now.
-No, no. We're partners.
C'mon, we got this, buddy.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-The pressure's on me right
here. Here we go.
I don't know what these are.
And -- okay, go.
Kid doesn't go to school.
He goes to a Cubs game.
-"Ferris Bueller's Day Off".
-That's right!
[ Ding ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Come on.
I love Ethan Hawke. Oh, my gosh.
This is great.
Alright, we can only go
downhill from here.
[ Laughter ]
All right. Here we go.
For this round, we're going to
make it a little tougher.
We're only going to have
3 seconds to do it.
Let's put 3 seconds on
the clock.
You're up first.
Whenever you're ready.
-Okay.
♪ Hey Mr. Tally man,
tally me banana ♪
I starred with her in
"Reality Bites."
-Yes, of course.
"Beetlejuice!"
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank goodness.
Yeah, I had more than
3 seconds.
That was the best.
That's the best scene,
with the shrimp.
Yeah, yeah, I love it.
Winona is --
alright, here we go.
All right, here we go.
Can I have 3 seconds on
the clock?
Give me an easy one.
And ooh!
[ Laughter ]
Man looking for a soldier.
Mr. Rogers.
Forrest Gump.
[ Laughter ]
-"Saving Private Ryan."
-Yes! Oh my gosh!
[ Ding ]
How did you get that?
That's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God!
Dude, I --
-I think I lost.
-There's so many --
-I took too long.
-I can't say Tom Hanks,
can't say Matt Damon.
I'm like -- [ Babbles ]
Whew!
Let's put one second on
the clock here. This is real --
-One second.
-This is it.
You basically got to make
a noise or something.
I don't know what it is.
And then
that'll summarize the film.
You're up first.
-Okay, ready?
-Yes.
-Bowling, White Russian.
-"Big Lebowski!"
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, we're almost -- this is
almost a perfect game.
This is almost a perfect game
right now.
Oh, my gosh.
This is unbelievable.
Okay, this has never been done.
Phew, I'm sweating.
Oh, my gosh.
Alright. Whew!
One second on the clock.
-Whew.
-Ready, and --
[ Groaning ]
[ Laughter ]
-Adrian? No.
[ Groaning ]
-Oh! Uh, uh, uh, uh...
[ Buzzer ]
-Hey.
-Adrian. "Rocky!"
-Yes! Come on, now.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That's Ethan Hawke.
"The Good Lord Bird" is now
available on Showtime!
Stick around! We'll be right
back with Ilana Glazer.
Come on back.
-♪ Check it out,
get down with tune ♪
♪ To the sounds of a heart,
to the 00... ♪